dancy nor is a longtime Republican
analyst and a former advisor to House
Speaker Paul Ryan he's been in touch
with Republican members of Congress
since last night's GOP loss dan good
morning I could not go to bed I couldn't
believe you'd be vouching so you were
talking to GOP members what are they
saying and sort it out to us how big is
this well most Republican members
including the leadership are relieved I
mean Ryan and I'm not gonna I'm not
going to quote people specifically but
generally they are relieved because they
recognize that they're heading into a
tough year in 2018 the house in
particular is really up for grabs and
the last thing they want is the
Democrats to be able to tell every
Republican on every ballot you own Roy
Moore so in that sense Roy Moore not
getting elected is a big win that said
it is a wake up call you know Alabama
Donald Trump one by one with 62% of the
vote all right if you look at the exit
polls voters who turned out in
yesterday's election their view of Trump
is way down the Trump's approval rating
among voters who turned out now a Bama
yesterday 48 percent this is one of the
most Republican states in the country
Democrats have outperformed this year so
far in special elections in Georgia and
South Carolina in Montana and Virginia
conventional Republican ed gillespie
lost by nine points Democrats are
raising money and they're recruiting
candidates for a lot of congressional
offices yesterday's a reminder that
Republicans may have a rough road in 18
I've never seen a Democratic senator
elected that so many Republicans cheered
for right because of what happened what
does this mean for the future of Steve
Bannon the president's former top
political director well I think it's a
big setback for Steve Bannon and the
president in that first of all the idea
that Bannon can like sort of select a
slate of candidates never they have the
ban and bag backing that's all it's
gonna take I think that myth has been
punctured and for the president I think
it's a reminder that he is this unique
political animal you know what I mean
the idea that people could become mini
Trump's you know there's this idea that
I'll just run like Trump ran and I'll
win it doesn't work
Trump is this unique character in
American politics and it doesn't
necessarily transfer and he doesn't
necessarily have coattails but you you
said it's a wake-up call but is it a
wake-up call to President Trump that he
needs to change his behavior because
he's going to be on the ballot in 2018
every one of these races or is it a
wake-up call to the establishment
Republicans who need to try and find
distance though you can from a president
I think it's both
I think congressional Republican see
even more urgency to get this tax reform
bill passed even though it would be a
win for Trump they just need to show
we're getting stuffs done we're doing
things Republicans want people to say we
are actually legislating we're governing
sort of with or without Trump's
craziness I think it is a massive
wake-up call for President Trump I mean
I just think everyone's saying his
approval ratings are low as approval
ratings are low he's governing as though
he's just governing the base of his
party yesterday was sort of still
tweeting this morning about I was right
I knew he couldn't win the general right
well it's hard to say when you came out
and started campaigning the reason that
doug jones won was the women's vote and
you see a record number of women running
for Congress and the boy now you have
and now you have a record number of
senators and legislators women calling
for Donald Trump to resign based on this
issue after he essentially and in
senator Warren's words slut-shamed right
senator Kirsten Gillibrand right where's
the Republican Party on that I'm look I
think the Republicans have a lot of
female candidates that they've recruited
there's a lot of female members of
Congress I've only from you know Elise
Stefanik who's the you know the youngest
member of congresswoman I mean they've
in the Tennessee race March of Blackburn
is running for bob Corker seat I'm not
worried about women candidates running
Republicans are worried about you see in
2016 when Republicans thought that
Hillary sorry when Democrats thought
that Trump would be such a drag on the
ticket they missed the moment and didn't
recruit enough high quality candidates
of either gender so so there wasn't an
opportunity to really kind of put
quality Democrats on the ballot they
missed the filing deadline that is not
the case now
just as fivethirtyeight.com estimates
right now Democrats have recruited 249
candidates to run for Congress those
numbers are massive we gotta go we'll
talk about those in the future thanks to
everything that happened with Roy Moore
who rode in on a horse and ended the
night calling on God and Jesus well
interesting to see what happens there
thank you very much gives me with you
guys right bringing in the horse image
yes
was an image it was an image